in the last video we had
a three-dimensional surface where the
height z
was a function of x and y and it gave a
surface in three-dimensional space now
let's try to get our heads around what
the gradient of a
of a
of a function of three variables looks
like so
the easiest one for me to imagine is a
scalar field so what's a scalar field
one that i find fairly intuitive is
temperature in a three-dimensional room
so let's say the temperature
that the temperature in a room is a
function of where i am in the room so
let's say it's a function of my x
y
and z coordinates
and i don't know i have never actually
modeled temperature but uh let's say i
have a i don't know a 20 kelvin
actually let me make sure that our
vector field works out right let's say
we have a 10 kelvin heat source in the
center of our room and so i can imagine
as you go further and further away from
that heat source it's going to get
colder and colder so let's say that the
temperature function and let's say
that's that center of the room is at the
coordinates x y and z is equal to zero
so let's say our temperature function
i'm just making this up i don't know if
this is an accurate model of temperature
it's equal to
now let me i keep saying 20 but let's
say it's 10.
let's say it's it's equal to 10.
times
e to the minus
r squared now what about why did i say r
as a function of x y and z well i'm just
saying
that it's it's a it exponentially decays
as you get further and further away from
that source kind of radially further and
further away from that source so what's
what's a radial distance away and this
is actually isn't that relevant to
learning gradients but let's get a
little intuition about what that actual
temperature function uh how it actually
changes as you go through the room
so the radius away from the center
that's just going to be
the radius as r squared is just x
squared
plus y squared plus z squared that's
just the pythagorean theorem in three
dimensions so let's write our
temperature function so let's write
temperature
as a function of x
y
and z
is equal to
e
to the minus
x squared plus y squared plus z squared
which is exactly what i wrote up here i
just instead of writing x squared plus y
squared z squared i wrote r squared just
to kind of give you the intuition that
this expression is just saying the
square of the distance as we get away
from the center of our room or from the
uh the coordinate 0 0 0 but that's not
what we're learning here but i want you
i want you to understand at least
conceptualize this it's hard to draw a
scalar field all a scalar field means is
that in any point in this space and in
this case we're dealing with
three-dimensional space at any point in
that space we can associate a value and
that makes sense if you were to take a
thermometer and measure any point in
space in the room that you're in right
now you would get a temperature you
wouldn't get a temperature and a
direction so it's not a vector field you
would just get a temperature and that's
why it's called a scalar field
associated with every coordinate is just
a temperature
so
what would be how would we view the
gradient of this function
well the gradient of this function is
going to tell us in which direction and
actually the gradient of this function
is going to generate a vector field
because it's going to tell us in which
direction do we have the largest
increase in temperature and also the
magnitude of those vectors in that
vector field will tell us how large of
an increase in temperature we are
looking at or you can kind of view it as
a as almost a a three or f well i'll say
a three dimensional slope
i hope that doesn't confuse it so let's
just take let's compute the gradient and
then i'll show you a diagram that might
make things a little bit more intuitive
let me erase
this thing down here
and i'm going to switch from this blue
color because it's a little
it's a little nauseating
so the gradient
of t
is going to be equal to
the partial derivative of t
with respect to x
times the unit vector in the x direction
plus
the partial derivative
of the temperature function with respect
to y
times the unit vector
in the y direction
plus
the partial derivative of the
temperature function with respect to z
times the unit vector in the z direction
and now we just plug and chug and figure
out the partial derivatives
so the gradient of t
is equal to
now you might be daunted oh you know i
have a e to this you know three variable
uh function how do i take the partial
term remember if you're taking the
partial derivative with respect to x you
just pretend like the y's and the z's
are constants so let's do that
so the derivative let's take the
derivative of
the inside function that's what we have
here so minus x squared plus y squared
plus z squared with respect to x so you
could you could distribute this minus if
you like so it'd be minus x squared
minus y squared minus z squared
so the derivative of that with respect
to x is just going to be these are just
constants so they have the derivative
with respect to x is just 0. so the
derivative is minus 2x right
minus 2x is the derivative of minus x
squared
minus 2x
times the derivative of the outside
well what's the derivative of e to the x
the derivative of e to the x is e to the
x that's why e is such an amazing number
so in this this 10 here this is just a
constant that you know when you take the
derivative uh
of a constant times something it's just
you the constant carries over so the
derivative of the outside function you
can or the outside expression the way i
imagine it is equal to 10
e to the minus
x squared plus y squared plus z squared
and then all of that times
the unit vector in the i direction
right
and now we can do the same thing for the
y
direction
so plus what's the partial derivative of
this with respect to y well it's going
to look very similar the partial
derivative of this inner function with
respect to y
it's minus y squared so it's minus 2y
minus 2y
and then the derivative of the whole
thing is just itself again
so times
e to the minus x squared plus y squared
plus z squared
and then all of that times the unit
vector in the
y direction times j
and then finally
the partial derivative of this respect
of the temperature function with respect
to z and that's just
minus 2
z
times 10
e to the
minus
x squared plus y squared plus z squared
this is just the chain rule and i'm
treating the other two variables and i'm
not taking the partial derivative with
respect to his constants
and then all of that
times
the unit vector in the k direction
and we could we could simplify this a
little bit you could have you know minus
2x times 10 that's minus 20x
let me write it up here so
so the gradient
of the temperature function is equal to
minus 20
e to the
minus x squared plus y squared you
probably can't read this plus z squared
times i
minus 20
this is minus 20x minus 20
y
actually i'm not going to go into that
because i realize i'm running out of
time i think you can simplify this
algebraically
but anyway the more important thing is i
i always find with gradients it's easy
to calculate them but the intuition oh
sorry this is also included this is a k
right here
the harder part is the the intuition so
let's get an intuition of what this
gradient function will actually look
like so what would happen if you wanted
to know the gradient at any point in
space you would substitute an x y and z
in here so the gradient function is
actually a function of you could write
it as you know
the gradient function is a function of x
y and z
but it's no longer
remember t to the temperature at any
point was a scalar
field at any point in three dimensions
it just gave you a number now when you
have the gradient at any point in three
dimensions it gives you a vector right
because it has i j and k components
where the magnitude are the partial
derivatives and then the direction is
given by i j and k
so we've gone from having a scalar field
to a vector field and let's see what it
looks like
and let me make it bigger so we can
explore it a little bit
i think that's pretty good
so this is the vector field
this is this is actually the gradient of
the function that we just
solved for
and as you can see at any point and when
you know this computer uh that this
graphing program that did it it just
picked different points and it
calculated the gradients at that point
and then it graphed them as vectors so
the length of the vectors
are just the magnitudes of the x y and z
components and and then you you add them
together like you would add any vectors
and then the direction is given by the
you know the relative weighting of the i
j and k components
and as you can see the intuition is
pretty
interesting
as you get closer and closer to our heat
source the rate at which the temperature
increases
right the vectors as you get closer get
bigger and bigger and let me zoom in
let's actually let's actually fly in to
the vector field
so we're now within the vector field and
you can see as we get closer and closer
to the center of our heat source
the vectors the rate at which the
temperature increases gets bigger and
bigger and bigger anyway i hope i didn't
confuse you what i i when i first
learned gradients i think the the
computation is relatively
straightforward it's just partial
derivatives but the intuition is always
the the interesting thing and hopefully
uh this temperature analogy or not even
analogy this temperature
this temperature model will make a
little sense to you but it applies to
pretty much any scalar field anyway i'll
see you in the next video